vous êtes con à la gare qui variés dans
un instant et la gaffe quand il arrivait
dans l'émission est et comment mais est
ce que vous vous avez peut-être un signe
distinctif voilà ce qu'on pouvait faire
à nos téléspectateurs et on noté le truc
qui préfèrent voilà vous quand vous
arrivez dans une émission jonathan que
ce soit et comme la gaffe qui est un
truc il s'est allégé benjamin castaldi
casas à cagnes à l'abri des aléas
chaunac tristesse
[Applaudissements]
or les mines à imola bonne note t on
[Musique]
ah non non mais attendez ya rien de plus
angoissant avec les mecs qui frappait
les mêmes motifs hausse a atteint 4
gâtés
bahia les mecs qui peut pas laisser
pratiquer michel mr a les bases du
public aussi des gens qu'on attend du
btp du vernis à xinhua
[Applaudissements]
ça
est-ce que je peux crier non une
habitude franchement non on n'est plus
dans ce délire non mais laissez lui
rendre un accord maintenant non encore
d'accord je sens que je vais avoir de
blanc vit de manière décalée canal
décalé catone bout alors ça va être à
temps sur alors là retour en arrière
c'est soir ses fans en panne à lakota
c'était quoi c'est pas la madame mélo
qui dit elle a rien compris paname pas
là mon arrivée toi tu as tu une apporte
quoi elle en fait moi c'est neuf ça
dommage au pays basque
vous allez voir moi je me sens pas du
tout je suis sûr que ça va être le plus
triste de tous sinon si c'est bien
possible
et si bon chemin j'ai senti mon
attention je compte sur vous ouais bon
ben moubamba obama et ben voila merci
d'un public alors s agit de manière
choix qui chérit
aux armes citoyens
[Applaudissements]
desserrez bsd vous voulez qu'on dise
voilà c'est ça non bizarre aux armes
c'est géraldine maillet c'est géraldine
maillet on va tous vous croyez qu'on va
mettre du nick longhi ouais alors vous
suivez un invitation avec kenny des
idées 2
j'ai ma gueule tu vas bien fait sur le
prime oui mais en optimisation du
travail
c'est pas mal c'est efficace ces slogans
gptc du parti s'improvise à sion